so today in Brussels it's car-free
Sunday which is an annual event which is
hosted to promotes cycling and using
public transit and I have to say it's
already made the city a lot more livable
actually and especially because I live
next to this kind of busy road it's
amazingly quieter today although I've
guess I guess they made a exception for
taxis and ambulances and stuff like that
now at first I kind of expected this ban
on cars seriously in the city centre but
the entire provincial region is just
completely Carles now and normally there
are so many cars you can't really admire
this roundabouts but today it's just
cyclists everywhere so you can finally
like look around and see how nice and
pretty this actually is you've ever seen
that diagram comparing the amount of
space you could probably imagine that if
all of these people were driving their
own car and there was just like one or
two people per car we would have a
massive traffic jam over here
and here's the European districts with
the Schumann roundabouts which is
usually cyclists hell but today is
pretty awesome to cycle around so this
is one of the main center ring roads
around the city that are usually full of
cars as well and it's completely empty
right now so yeah these couple students
are kind of annoying to this icon and
you'll find them around the city centre
and other areas like this this is the
royal palace by the way or at least it
used to be the Royal Palace and
interesting tidbit
Brussels is known for its modern
architecture and really for destroying
half of its historic core and because of
that it's not really as popular as a lot
of your other European cities you'll
often find these modern skyscrapers just
altogether stuffed between the historic
buildings and that kind of ruins the
image now and then but I think there's
some interesting things to note about it
as well the city is really functionalist
above choosing for aesthetics so very
much of the city was destroyed to make
it more functional to allow people to
commute easier and things like that and
because of that there is more
interesting mix of modern and old
architecture
and while it's surely not that popular
and it's different from a lot of other
European cities it's something that kind
of makes the city unique as well you
find a lot of these very typical well
old-style European facades and districts
but then there's always some sort of
modern velocity Tower in the background
and
so you may have heard or seen some
pictures of the door which is that
really interesting round window shape in
it and it's in fact a really cool iron
nouveau building but for some reason I
think they're working on the door right
now
it's definitely not normally supposed to
look like this the door on the left
should have the same pattern as the
window on the right and it's normally a
really cool decorative sort of feature
of the building Brussels in general is
for really interesting irony of our
buildings really cool structures in the
park right there I guess you could go so
far as to call it a weenie maybe so
maybe I should use this opportunity to
talk a little bit more about what's
going on
and why I haven't been uploading for a
few months and why I'm in Brussels all
of a sudden so basically I spent much of
the summer vacation traveling across
Europe to visit cities and theme parks
mostly in Scandinavia and Poland and to
be honest I should have left more time
free to do YouTube related stuff which I
didn't because I underestimated moving
to Brussels which I recently did and
been spending most of my time on because
I'm studying urban studies at the free
university of brussels right now which
coincidentally is right over here
although it's not the nicest building of
the campus I would probably be the big
building with the spire which I just
passed but didn't really record a
commentary and now I'm studying urban
studies over here which is very much
related to my city skyline stuff so
definitely something I'm really
interested in and maybe something that I
might bring back in some my future
content now this is not to advertise or
anything but I've been going around
using the filler bike which is a bike
that you can rent costs about 160 a day
and you can use it for a half an hour
for free and every additional hours or a
half an hour is $0.50 so it's not too
expensive but I'll definitely get a
subscription at some point in the future
but it's just about the best thing I can
do for now
that said though the bike that had this
morning was absolutely trapping for some
reason the fourth gear kept skipping and
I was constantly afraid of the chain
falling off
[Music]
but it's fine overall trend rules rights
in the middle of the bicycle path really
annoying kind of dangerous definitely
not something that I like very much and
god I had to keep turning off the camera
here and there because I don't feel
really safe cycling around between tram
rails and filming at the same time but
yeah overall this is basically where I'm
at so that's why I haven't been
uploading so much recently but now that
everything's kind of settled and I
should be moving into a more regular
lifestyle again hopefully I'll get back
to cities now - planet coaster as
quickly as possible
another note to add I'm not sure how
much I can review about that but I've
also been working a little bit more on
architects I've never really revealed
much of this in the first place but I've
been doing some stuff related to
scenarios and as soon as these scenarios
come out in the full game of politics I
will be doing some videos of those as
well so yeah they have it a bit of an
announcement in any case I'm almost
there so thank you guys for watching I
know this is a bit of a random video but
it's really an interest of mine I think
it relates kind of to the city skylines
videos that I've been making as well
seeing how focused on sustainability and
using transportation methods other than
cars they are and yeah I hope to see you
guys soon in a new vlog of the theme
park or some kind of planet colu City
skylines game related video bye guys
[Music]